okay so I'm a little late to this party
but the Michael Morbius trailer looks
amazing see here's here's the thing I
love what Sony's doing right like I love
what Sony's doing right now and I think
it's good they finally found their
footing but because for the longest time
Sony was just cranking out spider-man
movies right it was a Spider Man movie
like one two and three which I thought
the Tobey Maguire movies were okay but I
never thought they were all that great
and then you've got an amazing
spider-man with Andrew Garfield which I
loved Andrew Garfield as spider-man but
I feel like the second movie was kind of
awful I just kind of rushed and awful
and and so on
especially electro I think it was just
kind of like a totally wasted scenario
but it's not like Sony was just kind of
retreading water you know like one of
these days we're gonna make a great
spider-man movie and people looking love
it you know that was kind of the
philosophy of Sony I'm glad they found
their footing in focusing on villains
because like I've actually like like
given the direction Sony's go so he's
going in I've got this full-on plan to
like to basically do stuff with Sony
that would blow what Marvel's doing out
of the water and and I think it would be
cool you had to kind of see it all to
kind of see it all go down ah but the
fact remained Michael Morbius looks
awesome now here's the cool thing about
it right like you know if those you guys
who saw the trailer there's this panel
on the wall
we're like spider-man's labeled as a
murderer and then you have Michael
Keaton at the end of the trailer which
shows us that like the vultures they're
into that or Michael Keaton's in the
Michael Morbius movie which is somehow
not tied to the MCU even though it is
and it's a massive coincidence right but
obviously it's connected to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe given the fact that
spider-man is labeled a murderer it
looks like it takes place after the
events of spider-man far from home so it
looks like it kind of continues on from
there I think as cool as Sony's bringing
things closer in line but my question I
cure yosity right because if you go back
and you look at amazing spider-man 102
which i think is where Michael Morbius
first appeared it was as weird Senoia
right right
you know Spiderman was coming out of the
story where he had six arms and and like
Curt Connors was there and ultimately
like Michael Morbius ends up showing up
and in the United States and then it
ends up getting to a fight with that
with spider-man and Curt Connors and
then bites Curt Connors right and so dr.
Connors goes from being a lizard back to
being a regular person and then him a
spider managers like holy crap basically
like this guy can cure us so let's do
what any superhero would do in his
circumstance let's force him to give him
some of our blood or is gonna give us
some of his blood
so what he ends up doing
there at least what spider-man and the
lizard end up doing is tracking down
Michael Morbius he end up getting into a
fight with him they take some of his
blood and then they use it spider-man
six arms go away and Curt Connors goes
back to being human for a while but it's
it's it's cool because my question is
how does this tie into the grander
scheme of things right because because
when you look at the idea of what's
going on with venom venom so a weird
situation right now there there is in my
mind there's a foolproof way like that
to throw venom in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that can be done quickly and
easily right just in the simplest of
ways um then I think worse splendidly
but with with Michael Morbius what's the
big picture here
right like you know what's what's the
point of Michael Morbius because when
you when you look at that I guess you
could kind of make an argument that that
with this story you get them focusing on
villains my question is is it going to
go to sinister six in reality if they're
bringing them closer in line with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I wouldn't do
that at all I would I would bring in
Michael Morbius and then bring in the
rest of the other midnight sons and then
do that right like the midnight sons
storyline right that just the whole
thing where you have like either that or
something that would be really really
cool would be the Doctor Strange black
ops team right so here was a thing right
though the Michael Morbius trailer kind
of kind of deviate from this for a
second he was a cool thing in the 1990s
and even going back further Marvel had a
team called the defenders which went way
back right he was a Silver Surfer it was
the Incredible Hulk it was Doctor
Strange and Namor the Submariner I think
was part of the original defenders not
gonna swear to that off top my head but
in the 90s Mobile didn't really know
what to do with it as what they did as
they handed it over to dr. strange and
the him the defenders became a dr.
strange story and Doctor Strange would
basically take like these these like
teams that the the roster would change
all the time right so on one roster you
would have Wolverine and Cyclops and
blade and like Thor and then like on
another roster you would have the
Incredible Hulk and then you'd have like
Iron Man and you'd have like you know
some other characters you know something
like that but but like titania or
something along those lines and maybe
maybe like volcana
you know or something else but you
basically have these characters and what
they would do is Doctor Strange would
take them on these missions into like
the other dimensions and they would
basically be a black ops team right they
were going like these surgical strike
missions they're a strike force and it
was amazing right but um I see Michael
Morbius coming into conflict with blade
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
would be badass
that would be amazing but again you know
as far as the trailer itself it looks
awesome like it looks absolutely amazing
and that's what I think it's so cool
about this right is is so defining their
footing and Sony focusing on villains
and not focusing on heroes um
the notion the idea of like venom Forge
they have a lot of people were just kind
of like okay and it's the thing that's
there you know and and I didn't really
get all the height that it deserved but
I thought was a fantastic movie for what
it was right it was a great start to
focusing on a villain verse which was
really really cool Michael Morbius
continues that trend I love they're
keeping the keeping the themes pretty
strong to the comic groups and so far as
he's basically a a guy from Greece he's
like this he's but he's not a physicist
he's some kind of like biomolecular
engineer so anyway basically as a blood
disease and literally like the blood
disease he's always trying to cure in
the comics what he did is he took he
took vampire bats and an electroshock
therapy which basically like resulted in
him essentially being a kind of pseudo
vampire right so he has to feed on on
human blood were to keep doing his thing
he's basically a vampire by all
standards of measurement he has he's
averse to sunlight different things like
that he walks around at night you know
so on and so forth I'm kind of curious
what I mean but the funny thing about
this is that the trailer doesn't really
give us enough to be able to say like
here's what the movies about in its
entirety right and the big question to
ask here this is the real question to
ask is he gonna come into conflict with
spider-man that's the big question to
ask here because I feel like if we don't
get an answer if spider-man 3 will
certainly get you know not me wanna know
why we wouldn't get an answer there but
well certainly you know if we don't get
an answer here we would get in
spider-man 3 but I would like to see in
some former fashion the movie kind of
showing some measure of the fallout with
spider-man and I think that would give
it more cohesiveness you know like the
movie kicks off with like you know
Michael basically sitting in some lab
and grease or you know doing doing
something you know and it's like man you
know like in other news today there's
like some news clip in other news today
you know spider-man is on the run he's
on the ground nobody knows where he is
you know and this is after his identity
as Peter Parker was outed by Mysterio
you know and it's spider-man far from
home spoilers for like a two-year old
movie or how long that movies been out
but still you know it's I think it'd be
kind of cool and it will provide some
cohesiveness but what I think would
really come out of this
as having other characters that you
wouldn't normally see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like some more
ground-level characters right having a
meet having an encounter blade that
would be a fantastic idea about you're
having an encounter blade or like
there's rumors of blade right even in
Michael Morbius doesn't really meet
blade maybe somewhere along the line he
meets like other vampires right and
they're like hey man like it's cool
you're one of us now but make sure you
watch out for that date Walker guy cuz
he'll kill you
you know that'd be kind of cool to see
something along those lines I would dig
it but um but yeah I would I would love
to see them go the direction of the
midnight sons like that would be cool
werewolf by night and all those guys you
know and that's kind of a funny thing
right because introducing someone like
Michael Morbius and and focusing you
know focusing on a movie that really
gives us like the darker almost kind of
horror slash mythological side of Marvel
it gives Marvel the opportunity to focus
like on that full-on mythological side
of things you know and so it would get
it we get you know pretty awesome but
for the trailer itself I love the tone
assuming the movie is anything like the
tone of the trailer it's gonna be
fantastic right it's gonna be an
absolutely awesome movie um I loved it
as Jared Leto I feel like Jared Leto
gets a bad rap especially after his
portrayal of the Joker which really
wasn't all that great the Joker is not a
mobster right you know the Joker is not
like Pretty Boy Floyd I don't want to
see that version of the Joker I don't
want to see Al Capone Joker
you know I wanna see crazy sadistic
Joker like like you know death of the
family Joker or like Steve Englehart
Joker where you tried to copyright fish
you know or something like that I want
to see those crazy versions of the Joker
ah so Jared Leto kind of got a bad rap
there but the great thing about Jared
Leto is if you ever saw like requiem for
a dream which is kind of the movie that
made his career he's an amazing and very
very versatile actor I think in this he
could be um he could be fantastic oh
here's the thing here's he was a crate
here's a craziest thing about it right
you see like you see what he looks like
when he's full-on like a vampire at the
end - he looks amazing
dude it's it's crazy it's pretty nuts
but overall I think the movies gonna be
fantastic and I'm really really hoping
I'm really really hoping here did it's
gonna be full of Easter eggs that's
really what I'm shooting for is we're
gonna get all kinds of Easter eggs all
kinds of little moments different things
like that seeing Michael Keaton seeing
the vulture there it's kind of cool I'm
you know I imagine that with the two of
them encountering each other I wouldn't
be surprised if we got the sinister
six right the original signature sex is
totally different right it's dr. octopus
it's it's uh what is it electro
chameleon and I came over the other ones
but I think Mysterio is part of the
original sinister six uh you know you
get those you get those kind of hair
this will be nothing like it but at the
end of the day sinister six is the
sinister six there's been so many
iterations of it the first sinister six
movie does not need to be the original
roster didn't need to be that way right
I mean you know like the II was at the
original Avengers movie like did they do
to have wasp right it didn't have like
ant-man Hank Pym you know it handle I
had like Steven I'm sorry I had like
Scott Lang so you can switch up rosters
right I mean I'm not so hardcore in the
comic so like it has to be the original
roster I used to be but then I was kind
of like you know didn't really make any
sense to get so upset about something
that I loved so because of that the
movie look something amazing it looks it
looks fantastic
I am excited for it I'm hyped just like
everybody else I want to know what you
guys think after seeing the trailer I
want to know what you guys think about
this but I think it's gonna be
absolutely awesome I think it's gonna be
really I think it's gonna be kind of
what we need in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like you know with with Sony in
the MCU I think it's gonna need like
focus on the darker side of things right
focus on the the darker horror element
of Marvel which is sorely lacking in in
level cinematic universe well let me
know do you guys think if you guys are
new here to comments explained wish you
guys did the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]